here's ryan pace the bears general
manager talking about the possibility of
drafting a quarterback this year despite
the mitchell trubisky experiment of four
years ago they've got andy dalton
they've got nick foles could they draft
a quarterback let's listen to ryan pace
drafted quarterback i do think it's it's
a good room for sure i mean those guys
are both have a lot of experience uh you
know
a lot of different experiences too which
i think is good and i think the coaching
staff that we have there at that
position is strong as well we talked
about it earlier with matt and with
laser and with flip it's a it's a strong
coaching staff around that position and
we have a lot of veteran leadership in
that room too so yeah to answer your
question i do think it's it'd be a good
room for a young player to enter
but again we're just going to take the
best players throughout this draft
as usual they say absolutely nothing and
the very real dynamic chris you and i
have discussed it
if they're tempted at all to trade up
i think virginia mccaskey is going to
have to sign off on that because you are
inviting a potential problem if you
trade up to get a quarterback if you
truly are evaluating whether or not to
keep ryan pace right coach matt nagy
after this season because if you let
them do it number one they're
compromising future assets in a draft
where it will be easier to gather
information and number two you you're
either guaranteeing de facto they're
going to be around to develop the guy or
you're walking into a potential problem
where you're going to be hiring a new gm
or a new head coach or both and saying
here's your quarterback right and they
may say we don't really want this guy
right right exactly what happened like
to what you said with matt nagy and
mitch trubisky right i mean that's where
i mean it started sour and i i how many
times did i talk about that mitchell
trubisky took the field for the first
game ever and it was a quote from matt
nagy saying he can't run my full offense
like hey welcome to chicago thanks yeah
great
so
that's where it's like
that that's where it doesn't make sense
to me and you're right you know the
mccaskeys i mean again at face value
you know there was a press conference or
a zoom statement last year about keeping
matt nagy and matt and ryan pace so that
leads us to believe of course that yeah
they were thinking about maybe cutting
the cord and that this is a big year
so
yeah at 20 at quarterback i just i i
don't i don't understand that you know i
really don't and to me the the thing
that i just come back to here with this
type of situation is i just think you
keep that conversation alive if you're
ryan pace because if one of those
quarterbacks do fall
that you want to again leave the
impression that maybe you will take him
so somebody will trade up to get him or
something like that that's what i come
back to more than anything i just can't
imagine they're going to try to groom a
quarterback when they need to win now
and need somebody to help them win right
now and why would they want to deal with
that
let me just deviate slightly yeah i
don't understand why pace and nagi are
on the hot seat that's a great
playoffs right two of the last three
years sure
and and this isn't the patriots the
packers
perennial playoff team where
oh hey well you you didn't make it the
third out of the last three years so
that's a huge negative against you
before 2018 yeah the year that began
with that quote you're still salty about
three years later right and they they
won the division that year
and but for the double doink they would
have advanced to the divisional round
right before that year
they had gone eight years
without a post-season birth right eight
years of no playoffs
before that 2010 2006 they they actually
had managed back to back somehow 2005
and 2006 but i'm there's heart there's a
smattering of playoff appearances since
that that great team they put together
in the 80s began to become dismantled so
i don't i don't get it
like it's working
you you've been to the playoffs two of
the last three years bears what the hell
are you doing
um but uh no i think it's a good
conversation it's a strange dynamic to
me maybe they would be better off
trading up getting a quarterback and
basically saying to the fans shut the
hell up and let's let this work itself
out well i mean i think that's where it
starts it is like the fan pressure of
course that starts this conversation you
know again okay so yes two out of the
three years there's no doubt about that
let's do make it clear that they were
the seventh seed this year which in most
years you know this was the first year
you get in but regardless you get in so
i don't want to take that away from them
but yeah i think it isn't i get an
interesting psychological debate why did
it get to this point you're right to me
it's like
one ryan pace messed up drafting the
quarterback right so that that was the
launching point for everything you could
have drafted mahomes and watson what the
hell are you thinking so that's put him
and that topic of conversation you know
on the hot seat then matt nagy was
supposed to come over and be an
offensive genius and we're supposed to
see andy reed eric b enemy high flying
offense and of course it's been the
opposite of that so there's like two
things that just the normal casual fan
can look at and go what the hell are
these guys doing here this guy's
supposed to be an offensive genius our
offense stinks this guy's supposed to be
a good gm he picked the stinky
quarterback so i think that's just
that's falling on their on their
shoulders there that blame there you're
right so and again
you know i think people in chicago
because i go on there a lot for the
regional sports networks and stuff like
that you know i think they looked at it
like their team
has been a little bit better than maybe
what they've seen on the field i think
that's the feeling there in chicago so
that that's where it's got to this point
but i think you're right we probably
need to be the ones that lead the charge
and say hey pump the brakes things have
been better than you know the the
perception around this football team for
sure
well and and this actually gets back to
the point we were making yesterday
about the ferrari the porsche and the
aston martin that choice the 49ers
are creating the impression in the
process of making because someone else
is going to drive the car that you don't
pick and you've got kansas city about a
seven hour drive maybe less if you have
a ferrari of porsche and aston martin
away from chicago they have to
constantly see every year what the
chiefs are doing right with the guy they
could have had and they didn't even have
to trade up to get him they didn't have
to give up what they gave up to go from
three to two they could have sat where
they were taken patrick holmes they
could have been the team that has become
what the chiefs currently are and they'd
be the team that's in the conversation
for championships every year i think
that
is what makes it worse so in my mind
we're trying to understand the
psychology here i'm not saying whether
or not
they should act on this
but even though they've been to the
playoffs two of the last three years the
fact that my homes became my homes the
fact that the chiefs have become the
chiefs the fact that you had
three cars to choose from
trubisky mahomes watson
you did pick the lemon
yes
you're you're you're you're teetering on
the brink of being fired despite being
to the playoffs to the last three years
that's the cautionary tale yeah right
for kyle yeah that's the thing that's
going to make that gray beard a lot more
gray between now and whenever we know
because it's not just tomorrow night
tomorrow night's the beginning not the
end tomorrow night's the beginning
uh we'll find out in one year two years
three years four years
did they pick the lemon or did they pick
the best of the bunch the bears picked
the lemon yeah
and and this is why i think
they're they're on the hot seat when
maybe they shouldn't be i'm with you i'm
with you you know shanahan the thing
that'll save him or saves him even with
some of the crappy quarterbacks he's had
there in san francisco you know he gets
style points because he's an offensive
coach and no human can watch the game
and go damn this offense is good even
though that quarterback's crappy the
damn offense just seems to always have
big plays people open a huge run so he
he has that benefit working for him in
that conversation to a degree but like
mike i just like i ask you
if you're ryan pace and matt nagy put
yourself in their shoes right now
you know justin fields is there at 20
let's say would you do it if you're them
right now you would yes if you're now
let's just go to you're the ownership
the ownership the people in charge
would you let these two guys draft the
quarterback at 20 right now
yes because this is our way if we get a
guy who works out this is our way to
to get the fans to forget about patrick
mahomes you're not going to forget about
patrick mahomes until you get your own
patrick mahomes not that he has to be as
good as patrick mahomes but but close
yeah and so you roll the dice on it this
is your only way out of the maze your
only way out of the maze right now is to
get yourself a great quarterback because
the fans for the duration of patrick
wilhelm's career are going to be pissed
off at the bears
unless and until they have a quarterback
who is relatively close so if you get a
chance to do it you go do it if he falls
into your laps i'm not saying you trade
up i'm just saying if he falls into your
laps at 20 right whether it's fields
whether it's a trey lance
if they're there i think you got to do
it because this is the only way to fix
this is the only way to to have a sense
of of consistency and continuity kind of
settle over the bears and you can act
like the steelers and hold on to guys
even when
you know and and that look
it's easy to be the steelers because
they rarely have these these horrible
stretches but
people still
jostle for mike tomlin to be fired and
what does art rooney do he ignores it i
think that's part of what you have to be
willing to do as ownership you got to be
willing to ignore it you can't
legitimize it by acting on it like the
lions did you know when the lions come
out 2019 with the bob quinn and matt
patricia will be back for a year but we
listen to our fans and then the fans
keep complaining and they fire them that
emboldens the fans to keep complaining
definitely once once you've proven
you're not listening to the fans
that's when you don't have this
revolving door and i think that's what
the bears need to figure out they need
to figure out that they got to quit
listening to the fans it's not like
they're going to stay home they're still
going to show up and one way to shut
them up as i said
get a quarterback who's close to patrick
mahomes or wait for patrick mahomes to
retire yeah it's gonna be interesting i
know like we've talked about i do think
there's a chance that somebody falls i
don't think it's that crazy uh that
maybe somebody is sitting there on the
board around 14 15 starting to get into
that range uh it'll be something to
watch for on thursday night because it's
it's an interesting discussion i can see
the logic going either way you make good
points you're definitely right that'll
silence some of the critics and haters
of the world and all that but i could
also say hey it's a rookie that we know
is raw and has some things he's got to
work on and now you're going to go into
the season with like wait we're just
kind of getting this offense kind of
going and now we're talking about
quarterback who's going to play
quarterback and that becomes a
controversy so it's that's where it's
it's a really it's intriguing that way
and uh i'm gonna be interested to see
what they do tomorrow night
bottom line
49ers you better pick the right car
tomorrow night because the other two are
going to be driving through your
neighborhood for the next 15 or 20 years
and you better hope yours isn't broken
down by the side of the road with a
hubcap over there and a wheel over there
and you know smoke coming out of the
front end uh uh it's hey
i i wonder if i wonder if we could
inject some sodium pentathol into kyle
and and get him to admit that he wishes
they hadn't made that trade when they
made that trade and just waited until
wait till the picks on the clock do it
then there's no time to think about it
there's no time to elongate the
discussion there's no time to
overanalyze it you just have to do it
maybe we can get him on here after the
draft at some point and we could pick
his brain about all that stuff and kind
of hear our process
i'll be interested to see how they spin
all this after the fact
i predict that one of the talking points
out of san francisco is going to be
it was that guy all along we were just
trying to create some confusion in the
hopes as you suggested yesterday that
maybe we could do a flip-flop and still
get our guy but we knew all along that
was our guy that was the benefit
of strategy we really weren't being
wishy-washy we understand these other
guys may pan out but this was our guy
all along yeah never a doubt about it
well and listen is there any like i
thought about this when we got done with
the show yesterday a little bit like is
it really that wrong
to make a trade
and be
70 30 right on the guy like is it that
wrong to go like like wait hey i'd like
to trade up i really like this guy and
you know what man i kind of like this
other guy too i mean i
alright let's trade up because i really
like the other guy but let's do our
homework and let me think about you know
maybe what i could do with this other
guy on offense and wrap my head around
in a little bit i don't think it's that
wrong or crazy to to think that so
uh maybe that's how they went into this
process i don't know but i'm i'm with
you mike i think that's how they'll
spend it when it's all said and done i
think you're correct
it's just unusual to put together that
gigantic package of three first-round
picks in a sec and a third round pick
excuse me for a player and you don't
know who the player is that that's
what's odd about right and and that's
that's where they open themselves up to
criticism uh and and hey they may have
been under pressure if you're ever going
to do it you got to do it now because if
you don't come up to three the panthers
are going to come up to three and you
can say goodbye forever to mac jones so
you know there's a story behind the
story as to what the dolphins did to get
the 49ers to jump when they jumped and
it worked yeah it worked right and we
don't know who else was at the table
yeah but the dolphins got their their
their extra two ones plus the 12th
overall pick plus a third round pick to
make that move when they did back in
late march
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports